when we hit the ie D it went off and I
just remember skies and sky sand and
thinking crap am i dead
am i dying like not knowing like that I
think in that instant that definitely
was my most afraid when we most afraid
well I was in obviously in World War two
actually started operating in April 1943
it was customary for pilots to go on
operations with an experienced crew
I didn't didn't really get to know
anything about the aircraft at all going
on that first operation well the cause
being at nighttime you see we didn't
have any vision of of land below you the
only illumination you got was from the
from the flat bursts so that the flat
bursts is like they're the guns on the
ground shooting up at yeah yeah quite
something because they burst in all
around you yeah I reckon that in the
Ruhr it was about 44,000 antiaircraft
guns just a few then it's a few yeah so
it was a matter of luck when you got hit
or not didn't make it easy for you that
no we were in the air
sort of for 500 600 aircraft but there
were occasions when aircraft got very
very close to you and you had to take
evasive action so that it was it was a
little bit frightening to put it mildly
if you were doing in in Afghanistan what
would actually your target our main role
in Afghanistan for the RF regimen is
force protection so aircraft coming in
taking off high-value assets around the
airfield and then going out to local
villages taking out doctors
veterinarians speaking with a local
seeing if there's anything we could help
them with get the locals onside hearts
and minds basically you have very much
close contact Taliban used to set off
IDF and direct fire which are basically
like rockets into the camps we would
mount up within five minutes and we'd be
off out the door
zooming across the bomb duty well origin
of fire and see if we could sort them
out we were on a Quick Reaction Force
air raid sirens had gone off the camp
had been rocketed we went out to deal
with it and a Taliban had set off a
roadside bomb I got blown up it rolled
and crushed and trapped for my vehicle
for three and a half hours shattered
every bone in my lower left leg I don't
really think I knew what was happening
to start with when we hit the I II D it
went off and I just remember skies and
sky sand and thinking oh crap am i dead
am i dying like not knowing like that I
think in that instant that yeah I think
definitely was my most afraid and I just
remember one of the lads just saying
[ __ ] good he's alive and then as as you
know he'd get taken off and I spent the
next sort of five six months in hospital
going through the surgery and the the
first part of that you know what's life
going to rely am I ever going to get
back walking properly again am I going
to be in pain for the rest of my life
being medically discharged obviously
that decision to leave is taken out of
my hands and the words of Monty Python
it's a scratch or a flesh wound as some
of my friends call it so yeah I had a
bad day at work what effect does
conflict have on your mental health
personally I think I've been very lucky
it it never affected me at all my
parents never asked me that they knew I
was flying on operations but when I came
home on leave they never ever asked me
about it
and I never volunteered any information
and I think that was general amongst
servicemen in those days I know that
especially in the recent conflicts for
instance in Afghanistan that they've
really gone through it for me obviously
losing my leg was it was difficult and
that but one of my most challenging
things was the the psychological aspect
the PTSD dealing with that 22 years old
I was a clinical alcoholic I was
addicted to medications you know plan my
own suicide didn't want to be here I
mean I remember when after I got
released from hospital and went home to
live with my parents for a little bit to
help me through my recovery when I first
started my parents would come into the
spare room where I was sleeping and
they'd find me you know asleep you know
chlorin at the wall screaming and things
like that and and in some ways I think
that was worse than the physical side
because that's more unknowing you know
people can see that but they can't see
what's going on in your head from having
to sort of try and pick up the pieces of
me piece of my life back together it's
only over the last probably 10 years or
so that people have started to talk
about it and I think it's only right
that the young generation today realize
what war was all about how do you feel
now about the enemy now in comparison
now you felt at the time I think it's a
difficult question actually I think you
know knowing back then what the Taliban
were doing they were doing they were
actively targeting members of the
military you know with IEDs you know
quite horrible things that I think most
of them are outlawed by the Geneva
Convention for example you know inhumane
against human rights in that but that's
irrespective so personally I you know
obviously going outside the wire and
Afghanistan you
didn't know who was a member of the
Taliban and you know who wanted to kill
you or who didn't you know there was
that uncertainty that constant
adrenaline and I think you know whilst
there are groups and organizations that
feel that way as the enemy as it were
that I don't think that's right
personally but that's quite difficult
one that I think at the time you know
when when they for instance with the
bombing of this country you felt a
little bit of hatred at that time I
think you realized that they were only
doing the same job as we were doing yeah
we were fighting for the existence of
this country and that they were the
enemy and they were killing us we were
killing them but I think since the war
it's become a lot more friendly for
example members of the Luftwaffe have
been very friendly towards us for
instance I went to last year I went to
Pina Banda which was the an important
ray that we took with the the ones and
the vetoes were being produced and I got
a very got a very friendly reception
from the German authorities over there I
lied a wreath on the memorial at
peenemünde er and it really was it was
there was no enmity at all between us
why do you want to tell your story I
want to I want to tell my story because
I think it's important that people know
what happened for me in Afghanistan for
troops so I think knowing about the
story and then my struggles with mental
health you know how I overcame them and
how I manage and deal with them on a day
basis I think that's important
people to hear and maybe you know if it
hits a nerve of them you know they're
going through something similar they can
come out the other side of it to
hopefully help them win it's only by
telling your individual stories that
they realize or they can realize how
serious war is the younger generation
are being told what went on and I think
it's only right that they should be so
that they can make their own mind up
about what's what's gonna happen in the
future yeah I have to say it's been
lovely to talk to you George and you
yeah and you self and thank you for your
service and everything that you did
thank you guys incredible days did you
do you did it yourself what did it feel
like with the mask you know so many
times when the actual adrenaline at the
time I was so happy I finally done it
and I know the facts of it I love it
it's it is incredible I've had like a
why section like an autopsy why cut okay
I see the beginnings already just yeah
I've got the scarification saying as you
go I've got I've got it on my got it on
my face that because he's such a lot of
tattoo work you can't see it but at the
time when I first got had done it was
like yours the red he was all bright red
I've got photographs of that